hi I'm Erik Bosse and this is a
breakdown of Rick and Morty season 3
episode 10 the season 3 finale the Rick
turian more to date I know I know I'm
bummed that the seasons already over too
but there's still plenty to talk about
details you might have missed some
deeper meaning behind why they decided
to end this season like this and a
couple of awesome Easter eggs they snuck
into the animation and before I start
thanks to our friends at kwid for
sponsoring this video quid is an app
that allows you to drag and drop
stickers on to text message threads
including Rick and Morty themed ones for
more details on that later okay let's
get started with this episode's title
the writer Ian morty dates this is a
reference to the manchurian candidate a
political conspiracy thriller from the
60s and later a 2004 remake it's about a
plot to assassinate a presidential
candidate and sneak in a brainwashed
commie puppet into the Oval Office now
that story line doesn't completely apply
to this episode it's honestly closer to
the plot of the Rick Lantis mixed-up
Citadel episode a few weeks back but I
do think the concept of a power struggle
between the American presidency and a
subversive force is a big influence on
this episode so let's actually go over
all the other real world pop culture
influences this episode in our segment
under the influence okay one thing you
might have noticed this episode were
these green location titles in the lower
thirds oh they're pretty unnecessary for
the most part like we know this is the
White House and Smith residence the
episode is just doing this as a
stylistic nod to political thriller
films that you might recognize it for
movies like enemy of the state and since
this episode is set mostly in the White
House the president makes some fun
references to American history Kennedy
sex tunnels naturally you'll forget to
some of them along with in order of
national embarrassment the truman
cocaine lounge the McKinley hooker dump
and the Lincoln slave Coliseum
he didn't free them all the Kennedys sex
tunnels are a reference to JFK's
notorious affairs including one with
Marilyn Monroe and the Lincoln slave
Coliseum is a reference to Lincoln's
Emancipation Proclamation which they're
joking was the cover for a darker truth
where Lincoln would have made slaves
fight each other like Calvin Candie and
Django Unchained now the president on
the show who made his first appearance
in the ditch with the episode has never
given a name but he's clearly influenced
by Barack Obama this episode gives us a
few references to the Obama
administration it's a young dumb people
considered in an honor to
work for president Rick could be
referencing the increased youth civil
service after Obama was elected
this included actor Cowpen who quit the
show house to work in the White House
Office of Public Engagement and then
there was this line let's set some
boundaries with a spoiled control freak
that thinks he runs the world and orders
drone strikes to cope with his
insecurity this could be a nod to
Obama's expansion of the use of drone
warfare but to be fair using drones to
kill people is something every recent
president has loved doing you may have
also noticed this old crusty looking
advisor to the president this character
looks like it could be some combination
of people like Steve Bannon or Dick
Cheney or Henry Kissinger back in the
day maybe some Winston Churchill thrown
in there and again yeah I'm not picking
a side here I think every president has
had some creepy old guy whispering in
his ear and later in the episode there's
this exchange Chyna doesn't piss on the
White House well why would they I'm sure
it was expensive this is a great line
that references China owning nearly half
of the u.s. is debt although apparently
recently Japan now owns more debt okay I
don't know I'm not an expert on global
economics either way it's safe to say
China has a crazy level of influence on
the White House okay moving away from
political references before I start a
war
Rick and Morty also reference plenty of
pop culture this episode treats us like
Ghostbusters Doctor Who in this
[ __ ] so yeah the device that
Morty's using kind of looks like
Spangler's PKE meter from ghostbusters
really both the Ghostbusters and Doctor
Who were regularly called upon by dumb
and inept government leaders to clean up
after them obviously both of these
things are huge influences on the humor
of Rick and Morty and then when they go
inside minecraft Rick calls out the
South Park reference South Park did it
four years ago Morty you're fast or
we're slow so yeah this is a reference
to the South Park season 17 episode
informative murder porn which the
parents play minecraft I just love how
all of these great animated shows
reference their past influencers so
South Park has a famously fast
turnaround with Parker and stone writing
and producing episodes within six days
which is a short enough time to cover
topical news events whereas Rick and
Morty as we know unfortunately has taken
two years between seasons also the line
South Park did it is a South Park
reference on another level
South Park coined the term Simpsons did
it to vent the frustration of the
substance that's covered pretty much
every possible storyline for an animated
show it
don't have a cow man
and actually that South Park episode was
also the see people episode with Cartman
creating a microcosm Society of see
people with rival religions who bomb
each other a lot like the Israelis and
Palestinians possibly an influence on
the conflict that Rick pacifies this
episode and the see people society
actually nuke each other to oblivion
which is possibly an influence on the
nukes of the mega gargantuans this
episode and getting back to the
Minecraft reference notice how later a
soldier ignites the president's portal
with a lighter this is a reference to
how the nether portals of Minecraft
require flint and steel to activate this
episode also referenced old movies with
can't be shrinking and growing effects
seventies shrinking party of one veneer
body awkwardly enlarges at the rate of a
50s movie
I think Morty was referencing the movie
the Fantastic Voyage which is
technically in 1968 movie either way it
was a past influence on the anatomy Park
episode and the 50s movie mentioned was
probably a nod to the attack of the
50-foot woman now Rick's battle with the
president through the White House was my
favorite sequence of the episode I'll
get to all the little immiscible
animation details later but a few pop
culture influences here the gun that the
president uses to lift and smash Drake
on the floor looks like the gravity gun
from half-life 2 he also uses this
remote-controlled satellite laser which
could be a reference to the hammer of
dawn and Gears of War or the heat laser
from the double-oh-seven movie dine at a
day now these twins who attack Rick
could be a reference to these psychic
kids from escape to Witch Mountain but
the way Rick fights them with this bo
staff looks like it's influenced by
Darth Maul's two on one battle in
Phantom Menace actually this episode did
name-drop Star Wars earlier an anonymous
American diplomat took them to a Star
Wars Cantina now the president's robotic
suit with the machine gun definitely has
this James Cameron influence to it like
it looks like it could be based on the
lifter from aliens or the suit from
Avatar
and these close-ups of the machine gun
rounds depleting is taken directly from
aliens also notice the way Rick creates
this energy shield and then rolls around
in it like a hamster this seems like a
visual reference to the Pixar film The
Incredibles way in - rolls around inside
violets shield through the jungle now
the other influence I caught came in
this scene between Beth and Jerry my
mind my ideas are all part of the
variable the only constant is you so
yeah in this scene Jerry is obviously
referencing Dean x-men b7 movie
okay no but I think this idea of a
chaotic frantic character needing a
soulmate as their constant to grab
himself is a reference to my favorite
episode of the show lost the constant
where Desmond's consciousness is jumping
around in time until he's able to
connect with penny his constant his
soulmate
now this episode ends with characters
eating Panda Express did you get sugar
chicken that's kind of the only thing
they have I just love how this episode
ends with a callback to the Smith
family's love of sugary Chinese takeout
back to Rick's obsession with McDonald's
Mulan statue on sauce and the season
premiere by the way McDonald's just
announced that they're bringing that
sauce back for one day on October 7
which is awesome let's run through all
the other in series continuity callbacks
and our segment backs so early on
episode the president describes the
creature in the tunnels this way some
kind of alien
Guga has infested the kennedy sex
tunnels Guga is a callback to one of
justin roiland and Dan Harmon's old
channel 101 shorts and I mentioned
Anatomy Park before but this episode
makes two references to that episode
first Rick making fun of the president
for shrinking with pills is reference to
the much cooler and faster shrinking
process in that episode before I get to
the second reference quickly because I
can't afford to work for free this video
is sponsored by Quaid big thanks to them
quit is an app where you can collect
cool stickers cards and focal figures
for free on your phone if you use emojis
and stickers when you text your friends
quit as thousands of free stickers that
you can't find anywhere else from shows
like the just-released Game of Thrones
Rick and Morty Steven universe Bob's
Burgers Powerpuff Girls and Family Guy
cold hits like Breaking Bad and Star
Trek in fur games like five nights at
Freddy's and fallout you just drag and
drop these stickers in iMessage whoo so
long boring blue-and-white iMessage bad
and if you collect Funko pop figures
quit as those two now some of these
stickers cards and toys are super rare
and hard to get so good luck but the
good news is you can meet cool people on
quit take a look at their collections
and trade with them as easily and as
quickly as chatted with each other
there's also a new feature you can
showcase your collection buddy I need
stickers two images you already have on
your camera roll wish i got a profile to
have an iOS new stickers cards and
figures that you can collect for free
are released every day including a
surprise big new show coming soon okay a
second reference to Anatomy Park came
with this reveal about Rick Dan
he's not afraid of pirates and
remembered the ride in anatomy part
Pirates of the pancreas was Rick's baby
was my baby you know I got a lot of
pushback when I pitched it Morty I guess
I'm still a little defensive so maybe
the fact that he considers pirates to be
genuinely terrifying was the reason he
was so defensive of this rides value as
a thrill ride I also like how Morty
talks down the president here yeah I
learned about your job in school you're
a civil servant we're technically your
boss so this is a callback to all the
times we've seen Morty in school on the
show learning basic unimportant crap
that he never really uses all the
important stuff that more he learns he
learns for brick outside of school so
Morty is saying to the president that
he's so useless he was something he
learned in a classroom burn and I know
some of you were bummed that we didn't
see evil Morty this episode what Rick
does allude to him with this callback I
could be a clone I could be a hologram
we can be clones controlled by robots
control the special headsets that the
real Rick and Morty you're wearing while
they're in your mother this is a
callback to the reveal of evil Morty in
season one with the robotic Rick who was
being controlled remotely by evil Morty
with a special headset under his iPad
and a people their visual callbacks
there were Jerry's golf clubs in his
apartment to call back to his crappy
golfing skills and the meeseeks and
destroy' episode also in their cabin
they bring that framed photos snuffles a
dog from season one who's been showing
up pretty much every episode and the
post-credits scene has this meta fourth
wall break by mr. poopy butthole which
is a callback to the season two finale
post-credits scene which also featured
mr. poopy butthole teasing us about the
long wait for the next season and while
we're talking about this meta joke let's
cover all the other meta humor in this
episode with our segment so Matt so in
the opening scene of the episode there's
this white house janitor with the
glasses this is an animated version of
Rick and Morty writer Mike McMahan
there's also this line from Morty about
Minecraft meta yeah this is commentary
from the show on all the Nerds online
who overthink these episodes which yeah
includes us and in the final scene Beth
breaks the fourth wall this way real
family now in many ways things will be
like season 1 but more streamlined Beth
is commenting on how this episode
basically fixed and reset this season
restoring it to these simpler setups of
the first season now I'll take more into
that deeper meaning at the end but first
I want to point out all the immiscible
animation jokes in the background so
let's go through frame by frame and
zoomin in haints okay so when Rick jumps
through the portal into the white house
I love how he covers his martini with
the sand so it doesn't spill also notice
inside that Star Wars Cantina club in
the background there's a dancing
stripper alien creature I guess kind of
like the dancing Twilight girls in
Jabba's palace later when the president
sadly reflects by looking up the window
feel it closely the song that he plays
on this cable music channel is called
prisoner to my emotions by to Chee
Jenkins and the Jane connects that's a
made-up song for the show
now some of you have also pointed out
how Jerry's bathrobe has the Chinese
character on the back which translates
to the word week now the best part do
zoom and enhance on is obviously the
White House fight they revisits pretty
much all of the hidden rooms promised by
the president at the top of the episode
- these slave Coliseum
there's Truman's cocaine lounge which
has bowls of cocaine which the president
throws at Rick's face there are also
pictures of 30s and 40s era pin ups on
the walls and while shooting wildly at
the hologram Rick's notice how the
president takes out the two twins the
McKinley hooker dumps shows up as well
you can see piles and piles of these sex
workers skeletons which is just
frightening this area is also filled
with film sets depicting famous events
from American history suggesting they
were all produced as conspiracy theories
there's the Apollo Lunar Module
and the surface of the Moon so Justine
the moon landing was faked I actually
went into a theory back in episode 8
around that guy mr. Lunas that suggested
Rick helped the government faked the
moon landing which is why you might have
erased Morty's memory from his mind
there's also the car that JFK was
assassinated in a flying saucer maybe
the one from Roswell and the World Trade
Center towers from 9/11 which is kind of
a callback to Rick's 9/11 memory in the
season premiere that your memory of her
outdo between where you were on 9/11 and
your favorite sports uber there's also a
set of George Washington Crossing the
Delaware which is crazy because that was
a painting depicting a battle in 1776
not a recent TV news story that anyone
would consider a hoax like all these
things are just history
the Flying Saucer now there are some
even more miscible details when Rick and
the president smash up through the
floors and by the way hiding things
between floors of a building it's kind
of a classic Simpsons gag
one floor has a satanic worship ceremony
going on with a pentagram drawn in blood
and candles and my favorite detail this
episode there's also the skeleton of
rapper Tupac Shakur he's even flashing
his iconic sign now there are a few
conspiracy theories around Tupac death
like that he faked his own death or that
he's living in Cuba all of which are
also true factual history okay let's
move on to the deeper meaning of this
episode now I know a lot of you were
surprised that the season ended this way
and not with another big high-concept
game-changing episode like the recent
evil Morty Citadel episode and as much
as I do agree with you after thinking
about it I really do think that for Rick
and Morty to survive as an animated
sitcom after what we've seen in season
three it really needed to be rescued
from Rick Rick must lose the show has
tried to do this like at the end of
season two with Rick turning himself in
but when season 3 started this didn't
stick he broke out of prison he out
stood Jerry from the family and Rick
took over as the patriarch leading the
family on a series of over-the-top
adventures that left the other
characters feeling resentful and empty
inside each of the season 3 episodes
features Rick not really being
emotionally invested in any of these
goals just cynically commenting his way
through them avoiding therapy by turning
himself into a pickle drunkenly assembly
in a death trap just to prove to Morty
how lame superheroes are reminding Beth
that her childhood was a lie and she's
better off detaching from her life just
like he did but the finale episode
changed that Rick finally cares about
something getting Morty a selfie with
the president and he cares about this so
much that he achieves peace with a small
nuclear state and peace between Israel
and Palestine and battles relentlessly
with the president just to get the
selfie and he only stops when Morty
tells him that he already lost Jerry has
won back the family now how did that
happen because something else
unprecedented for this show happened
this episode events of the last previous
episode had a lasting emotional
consequence rather than just resetting
like nothing happened for Beth the
thought of being a clone sent her into a
tailspin and we still don't know whether
she's a clone but that's not the point
clone or not Beth needs simple honest
simple Jerry to keep her sane in
way this shows survival depends on Rick
losing his dominance over the family as
fun as these crazy season 3 episodes
have been eventually nothing on this
show will have emotional stakes with
Rick's absurdist cynicism setting the
rules each episode so instead rick and
morty needs rick to be the outsider an
agent of chaos the crazy grandpa in the
garage who drags Morty and the others
out of their status quo and by forcing
Rick to lose here at the end of the
season they can finally restore the show
to the balance that have had in season 1
a grounded based reality a dynamic force
to break them out of it and then a
grounded based reality to come home to
which characters do you wish made cameos
in this season finale evil morning Tammy
and Phoenix person I'm actually gonna do
another video and all the unanswered
questions that the season left us but
here let me know your thoughts on this
finale in the comments below and we're
gonna do another giveaway
Rick and Morty Funko pop to thank all
you guys for watching and sticking
around to the end and staying with us
all season just follow new rockstars on
Twitter and share a link to this video
with the hashtag new Rick stars and
we'll send some of you guys some of
these vinyl figures guys it has been so
fun breaking down the season of Rick and
Morty but we still plan to make more
Rick and Morty videos just keep an eye
out for those you can also hit me up on
Twitter a da vas and subscribe to new
rock stars for all of our Rick and Morty
deep dives and if you really want to
support this channel so that you know we
can eventually avoid having interrupt
videos with these ads you can contribute
to new rockstars on patreon big thanks
to all of our current donors especially
Kelly hopper alright guys thanks for
watching bye